thank you very much oh I'm so glad you
came back it's great to be back sounds
like you had a wonderful holiday did you
I hope you did I had a very quiet New
Year's I stayed home and watched Bruce
Jenner's ball drop but hey who's ready
for a little free speech in America what
do you say because they tell you
something if there was a theme to the
news and the time we were off it would
be no joking no joking there are people
in the world we just don't like you're
joking about them you know North Korea
they don't like it these [ __ ] in
Paris who shot cartoonists this week
they don't like it and as a jokester I
just have to say the world needs to
stand as one and to quote the immortal
Dick Cheney say go [ __ ] yourself and let
me tell you something we incredibly
courage and courageous death of this
French magazine Charlie Hebdo I'm
probably pronouncing that wrong but we
all know who they are
they said that loud and clear this week
as they announced yesterday only they're
gonna put out the next edition on time
but with a million extra copies yeah I
mean my heroes
compare that to Sony who pulled the
interview after one online threat
congratulations Sony you put up less
resistance in the French
Wow oh they're scaredy pent they also
shut down production on the next
guardians of the galaxy movie because
raccoons complained about their
portrayal but the good news is that
these two brothers who carried out this
horrible attack today got their wish
they're martyrs they were shot dead by
French police and a third jihadist who's
their accomplice also shot dead get this
maybe there is a God in a kosher deli I
just hope that the last thing that went
through this guy's head other than the
sound of the bullet was an old Jewish
woman complaining that the brisket is
too fatty
now we are learning more about these
brothers who had carried out the attack
they are as everyone suspected Amish
well you know what Howard Dean said the
other day he said they're not Muslim
terrorists you know he said they're mass
murderers he was gonna say more but the
elephant in the room sat on him but okay
so we're finding out that these two
brothers were radicalized by a fanatical
janitor I love that because you know
what a janitor he must have the inside
track on what God wants because God made
him a janitor Lester he put out a fatwa
on gum
also much like the tsarnaev brothers of
the Boston bombing Fame they were pot
heads they smoked weed but obviously not
enough
I tell you far be it for me to make fun
of religion but only religion could ruin
getting high and looking at cartoons so
meanwhile this week over in Syria Isis
beheaded a street magician finally we're
on the same page I have to think Charlie
Hebdo would like that joke and you know
the death toll at their office would
have been a lot higher except luckily it
was Paris in the middle of the day and
most people were at home having sex but
you loved it that everyone in America
finally is loving France again yes we've
left Ron's even the Conservatives Senate
Republicans are even considering
changing freedom fries back to french
fries
and all the politicians are getting in
the act chris Christie today pledged
that he would eat a whole tray of
chocolate eclairs and Bill Clinton said
he would proudly take part in the menage
tois